I'll just say others further away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we all greatly appreciate you spending
your Saturday is Saturday I don't know
is it was Saturday morning with us
in this with these gentlemen next to me
my name is Jesse Tom I game spot and I'm
here with the heads of the newly
established summer fall studios Lea Meza
and David Gaeta they're excited to be
I'm so excited you may know Liam from
his work at beam doc on helping bring
the game at X Convention to Australia
and working with the Game Developers
Association of Australia among so many
other things liam is a massive household
name in the australian games industry so
let me also introduce you to lesson no
name in the games industry uh sama for
creative director David Gaider now if
any of you don't know David kicked off
his career working on Baldur's Gate to
his credits also include neverwinter
nights my personal favorite RPG of all
time Star Wars nice Eon Republic and
Dragon Age coincidentally those games
also happened to be the reason I got no
sleep and had no friends in school so
thank you mr. Vader extremely same 100%
worth it wouldn't change a thing all
right so yeah we're here to talk about
you guys have just revealed your studio
and revealed your first game chorus so
for anyone who couldn't make it or just
wants to hear about it all over again
the yo keynote David from yesterday you
want to just give us a quick lowdown on
what we're gonna get to see in course
all right chorus is a combination of
narrative choice driven narrative game
and musical the musical portion of it
we're talking about interactive songs
where the player makes decisions during
the song that not only direct the course
of the music but also at the end of that
song will then direct the the course of
the story so really the the songs are
our boss battles
and that's that's pretty much there I
mean I know we've been talking quite a
lot about it and what a unique we had
trouble sort of even thinking of other
games that would much like it so where
did the idea originally come from to do
something so out of the box I think that
came from a bunch of places but when we
started summer fall we knew that we
obviously wanted to do a character and
narrative driven game because that's
extremely our [ __ ] that was a given and
but we wanted to do something different
something a little bit fresh and so we
sat down and we you know talked through
a lot of different options and Dave was
like what if we did a musical and I much
like you know big video which if you
which you should check out if you
haven't seen it was very much like a oh
hell yes like absolutely I want to do a
musical yeah cuz we initially when we
were talking we went it was the same
meeting where we talked about the studio
we just sort of skipped most of that
we're just like oh yeah cuz we need to
realize that we were very in sync on the
kind of studio we wanted to make on the
kind of game we wanted to make so when
we sat down we went very quickly from
should we start us to do - what will our
first project be and we started off with
the should we do an RPG that's where
both of our experiences and we don't
want to discount the fact we might get
there but I think for the first project
we want to do something a little bit
different and I had been wanting to make
an hour musical at Bioware for quite
some time it was sort of half jokingly
it's like it's like Mike Mike Mike Mike
Mike Mike I want to do musical dlc Mike
we can have it in the fade and he was
like okay if we get to 10 million sales
then it's like oh man so it was kind of
a joke but it you know in a way it
wasn't because when when Liam brought
this up he's like so if you could do
anything like well then you want to do
what would it be and it was a weird
question because it's like in my career
I've never had that choice right like
all right I guess this
this would be my studio I can do
anything
shop so I did it didn't take long
thinking I was like we could do music oh
yeah and Liam was Liam was right in on
that so my background is like I am a
huge musical theater nerd so I was
immediately like yes yeah what can you
guys tell us about the game setting so
chorus is urban fantasy so that means
that it has fantastical characters in a
contemporary setting so chorus is in a
world where the Greek gods have existed
through the ages in various forms and
live among people along with monsters
and various other brethren right
and in our game the protagonist grace is
holding auditions for her band and
having no luck at all they're all
terrible and then this this one woman
comes in and just blows her away and
this is revealed to be a woman named Cal
and she's immediately like yes you're in
and later that night she appears in her
apartment bleeding and before she dies
reveals that she is one of the Greek
muses the last of the muses and passes
on her power to grace and thus our story
begins yeah yeah hermes shows up and
said and hermes is able to he sees the
messenger god god of doorways he's able
to connect any two portals so he shows
up in her apartment and says he sees her
covered in blood and thinks that she is
clearly responsible it brings her before
the rest the gods and the rest of gods
are very upset and believe that she's
killed Cal and thus she's she's given Y
a month to if she if she is truly is in
exchanges and young
to figure out who's actually responsible
so in a way turbid fantasy but also a
murder mystery what is it like having to
introduce so many new elements obviously
you're working with some understood
concepts like mythology but also
injecting all of your own stuff you
probably have a lot of experience with
the Dragon Age and stuff but is there a
trust that the audience will just get it
or do you need to balance how you're
delivering lore and everything like that
combined with new characters and
mechanics well I mean yeah you're what I
usually I have experience with that
that's been my my primary
responsibilities the various games
worked on cuz you got to be careful with
sort of the information flow a little
bit of an advantage here is that when
we're talking about Greek gods you can
kind of safely expect a certain level of
knowledge on the part of the audience
like I mean somebody who knows
absolutely nothing might be at a slight
disadvantage sure you want to still give
them the base level of information but
have it be that you expect that
somebody's gonna know basically who
Apollo is right and and things like that
so that makes it a little bit easier
it's also urban fantasy so I don't have
to introduce ideas like what is a car
yeah so that that is I mean a so many
ways to introduce fantasy worlds that's
urban fantasy [ __ ] is way easier so
that'll be a nice a nice treatment yeah
and obviously you guys have quite a team
one of whom is Troy Baker uh what was
the decision-making process behind
bringing him on board aside from what I
she was just getting to hang out with
Troy Baker so if I ever make a game
about it he's an utter delight yeah it
was less of a choice on our part and
more of a phone call from him so we Troy
sort of first interactive the project
very early on we were we were just
working on our first like test song
essentially and he came on to do temp
vocals with Austin yeah and did an
incredible job of course he [ __ ] did
he's amazing pretty good he's like it's
like okay I guess
well he's like Austin is
where it's composed to the song it's
like oh I've got my friend Troy here who
- vocals and it wasn't
I didn't realize immediately okay
suppose Troy Baker is singing our temp
vocals got it
and it turned out that Troy and Austin
had been talking about doing a musical
for quite some time and so Troy was
pretty keen and later we were talking in
the office and being like we're really
gonna need a voice director because
we're not in LA either of us like days
and Edmonton and in Melbourne
fair amount of distance between those
places and LA and like within that like
13 it was the same day like it was so
close we got a call from Troy being like
hey so I've been thinking hmm do you
need a voice director and I was like
after he hung up I'm like no one's ever
gonna believe this story it was just way
too convenient but yeah that is exactly
how it happened and he came on board and
has you know I just like when Austin
joined the team like just immediately
like redirected the flow of things and
brought his own expertise and and talent
and so you know every every member of
the team who's come on has subtly
influence the project in various ways
and it's been really really would you
say it's changed significantly or is it
sort of the main thing you wanted to do
about manoeuvered slice them down it's
definitely reading it's absolutely a
thing you wanted to do invite just like
refined refine so you know when Austin
came on he's like he is how I think you
could do these choice sections if he's
like roughly how long I think these
should be and then when Choi came on it
was like okay he's how I think it should
be performed here's the kind of tone and
voice we need behind this here are the
kinds of people we want to be here and
in this in this this game I was about to
say show kind of is also show and so you
know everyone who's come on board has
just improved things and we've all been
someone in sync from the get-go it's
been incredible Austin was the critical
one I think is the we were talking about
having a musical game the first question
that came into her head was how are you
going to play a musical
like if you're in this song's we and I
already knew we wanted to interactive
songs and when I started writing the
songs that it became compared to me that
the the branching part of the songs I
had no trouble with at all it's like
that's not that different from branching
dialogue but how that affected how you
would write the music and write the
songs because when you're making the
choice it's timed but I do defects you
need a space in regular spaces in the
song where you make those choices where
the music kind of hangs for a bit
not long enough that that was the thing
- how long do we let the music hang if
it's if this are too long
then the flow of the song is sort of
affected if it's too short the player
doesn't have time to parse the options
these are all things we had to to
concern ourselves with and like but that
was going to affect how the music was
written didn't even occur to me until
Austin on board and he had ideas also
about how we were going to physically
set it up because the another thing was
that if you're when you make the choices
in the song the music changes like the
actual like if you take a more
aggressive option like it defiant option
suddenly drums start coming in and stuff
like that so it is a different musical
track but physically you have to avoid
the skip the the music actually changing
in tracks to get through which you know
Austin was instrumental as well as I'm
we brought in a tech audio tech person
called Steve green anyway that's boring
stuff really important to us make sure
that the game can function and yes
everyone everyone's just done an
incredible job of just seeing the vision
hmm and really finding new and exciting
ways to me what's it yeah there what
size is your current team my pretty
small I like like six people right now
what yeah is that like going into a
small team environment I mean what what
are the things that you've found what
better than when you're in a larger team
and things that are more difficult
communications a lot easier yeah I can
just shout across the room I mean that
that is a big thing in that I have found
there was a
when I was at Bioware for instance there
was a sweet spot where he got to about
70 or 80 people and then the company
really started to change and really III
have a theory that the the team size has
never actually changed no matter how big
the company gets they just you get
little isolated bubbles within the
company you just naturally don't your
group doesn't your Media Group doesn't
expand beyond that point and you really
had this sort of started getting
cultural divides in the company and
communication had to go through several
several layers and also but also
approval for anything had to go through
several layers so being on a smaller
team we can come together very quickly
make decisions as a group and everybody
feels like they they're being heard and
we want to make sure that they're heard
so usually just something happens and
you jump on it and maybe not maybe not
someone doesn't have the exact skill you
need so somebody learns the skill just
does it so it really feels like we're in
this together and I really I really
enjoy that feeling so far my favorite
part is being agile and being able to
work really quickly and I change
direction really quickly how do you say
agile and I start twitching agile agile
management is a thing in game dev that
they hate Dave hates production so when
I don't hate production I hate producers
that's not true there seem necessary but
producers yes creativity doesn't have a
schedule I know I know I'm an artist
yeah well I mean you guys launched about
almost exactly 24 hours ago and I think
you're just about to hit a hundred
thousand US dollars impressive
[Applause]
incredible um are you are you imbued
with the kind of confidence being able
to go into it with the team that you
have I mean as you mentioned Austin
Wintory Laura Bailey onboard as well I'm
sure a hell of a lot of other talent or
is it is the fact that you are still
sort of surging into the unknown a
little fracking you did mention how it
was a little difficult to get sort of
publisher support on something like it
was brand new yeah like we you know
we've been speaking to publishers for
the last year and a bit about this game
and almost universally everyone's like
this is a really amazing idea this is
really special I can see that you're
incredibly passionate this you are the
right team for this the right talent but
there's absolutely nothing like this and
so for us as a publisher to throw a
bunch of money at you that's a massive
risk when there's nothing proven to show
that it will work
and this is very common in game
development like this this happens with
a lot of projects most projects you
never hear about because they're too new
or too different and so somebody has to
prove that there's somebody has to prove
it and so unfortunately that's us and so
we decided to you know step out onto the
very thin branch of the tree and say hey
like we're making this thing that we
think is really cool and really special
do you think so too and so far like that
the responses that have been rolling in
have been just incredible so many people
have been saying wow it's like this game
was made for me um and it that's because
it totally was a slave we we'd spent a
lot of time talking about you know the
kind of game we wanted to make we wanted
to make a game for people who are like
us who you know love RPGs who love
characters who love narrative but maybe
aren't that big on combat yeah or
progression I mean those things are fun
we're gonna be wrong but I think there's
definitely an audience out there for
that they like these games maybe despite
those things that that really knit
they're there for a narrative for the
romance things like that and we will see
we will see if there's if there's man
musical element obviously is huge too
and we've had so many incredible
messages from people just being like yes
which which you know we're very own
blood flow because that was very much my
reaction when we started this project
yeah well speaking of narrative I mean
obviously that's definitely your driving
force for what you're doing here gee do
you guys think personally there is
enough being done to support that
well-crafted narrative based game in the
industry right now and if not is that a
gap you're trying to fill I think that
the support for narrative in games has
gotten better over the years I started
to sprint out more back in back in the
day they were only like you would count
on on one hand or the number of
companies that kind of focused on that
now it's spread out a lot more so I
don't think it's it's that that we're
doing something new on the narrative
scope I really think that that the new
thing we're bringing is that the
addition of the musical Elle and how
that fits into the overall narrative
because it is both when we were talking
to publishers like the very first thing
they didn't understand was okay how does
this interactive song thing work okay
once we got that out of the way the next
thing was so how does this work in the
context of the road game like what do
you do and that that was a cause I mean
a lot of games especially even narrative
games really they the the whole walking
simulator has been kind of the standard
right that you you when you are in the
shoes of your player you're in the shoes
of them for every every step you take
and every person you talk to the idea of
having a slightly higher level view
isn't very very common and and so yeah
we definitely had to work out the ways
in which we communicated and you know
the gameplay is very much like
dialogue-driven is a lot of talking you
have these beautiful environments that
you navigate through in like
point-and-click style and then you have
cutscenes and you have these songs and
once you see that in action it's a lot
easier to understand but it's very hard
to talk about and so we actually have to
show them having how that works and
we'll be will be showing a video with
more gameplay later in the campaign so
you
like what a whole like song what a whole
branching some looks like and that will
be the what we call the Minotaur song
yeah which was a Troy and Laura and it's
just very cool the Minotaur song yes a I
mean it was interesting i I don't
actually have a clip of that if you guys
could just give us a singer I do you
have them subway I mean I just think it
would give us like a really good picture
how that would work
um I mean I wish we can we can sing it I
know how the Minotaur starts that's the
the what it starts with the player it
does start with a player players
wandering around in the sewers hmm yeah
and yeah yeah this is the wrong script
that is the right script alright so uh
was it no no it totally it totally
starts with them oh you oh you're
correct I am wrong I'm not the creator
this song again but the scene search the
same oh yeah okay so the play is
wandering through the sewers um I just
had to scroll up um okay
you're not lost you're not lost
everything's fine everything is not fine
once we get to the song you'll be fine
oh and of course the Minotaur lines are
not boldface this is the players script
a word soul oh yeah yeah what what
wayward soul blunders in eyeshadow are
these your shadows ha ha ha just passing
through total accident
[Laughter]
who's this come into my lair
delightfully unaware did no one tell you
to avoid the home of those who render
limb from and the play guys um well
actually the plan has three options this
is one of them I think this is the key
and you guys I promise I'm no Izzy meal
the kind who beg and cry and kneel
there'll be no Jace no I won't run you
hardly have this battle one admit a
fondness for the tastes a flesh and
blood which has been laced with the tang
of rage and fear surely you don't think
escape is near I haven't been and I
don't long but even so I know the rules
watch me stop you with a song they'll be
no chase no I won't run I'm not gonna
let you have your fun
Brava Brava
these troops conferred with fear writ
large upon your face fight me if you're
so inclined
gosh how dare have you no respect this
game has rules which you neglect my song
my rules I think you'll find do not
blind me with your lies do you who dies
you realize you'll let me through and
stand aside no more to do but hey you
tried
I will admit that's quite the feat yet
this affair feels incomplete your power
strong that much is true but this realm
is mine you may only leave if I allow
you to then we'll make a deal you let me
go I'll do you a favor quid pro quo and
if the task that I should ask just that
bravery what else is new tell me what to
do then I agree
so the
the way the song would work functionally
he mentioned that there was the one
thing which was the kick-ass option when
he we would have gotten to the end of
the song where would I think it's why
the play interrupts yeah well there's
the interrupts that's one of the options
it's at the end where the the players
like you'll let me through and I think
in that option she doesn't have quite
enough flow so she has taken the lesser
option where he's like well you have to
do something for me and that that is
then the branching part of the end of
the song say before this quest you would
have done a little research in game and
found out a little bit about at the
minute or hopefully have to do the extra
homework you can just go into the song
blind and hope that you pick the right
options but um the idea is that you kind
of try to find out whether how the
Minotaur likes to be approached what
works with the Minotaur does the
Minotaur like to be persuaded
do they like someone who's really
aggressive every song is gonna have a
trick to it that you can investigate
before head and they may give you an
advantage and in in this song which I
don't even remember what he prefers it
was the kickass option but he he demands
respect so they interrupt actually works
against you yeah see there are options
in these songs that you know you've got
you've got it you've got to do your
research they've got a you gotta pay
attention and then at the end the idea
is that with the flow that you've built
up throughout the song you can the final
the final option in the song is sort of
like a menu to spend whether you're
spending for like they have someone fall
in love or to confess a crime or in this
case to let me through the maze that's a
very mechanical way of describing it yes
I would say you get to influence the
world
with the flow that you've built up yes
well that was the best moment of my pecs
obviously course is an incredibly
character-driven game so I want to ask
what the considerations behind writing a
really good character and most
specifically what you can talk about
what have been the considerations behind
the cost of characters that you
currently writing for course hmm what
makes a really good character hmm apps I
mean you're wrong I mean for this case
we have a lot of the the Greek gods
they're involved so one of the big
things we went in was trying to imagine
what would this character look like in
um in a modern setting like they've
they've been alive for thousands of
years now they're sort of maybe lost and
kind of dysfunctional like you know like
one of those stars that you know you
used to like a long time ago but now
they're just onto competitive dance
shows so what is this modern incarnation
of them how do they relate to grace are
they a romance that sort of changes how
we how we construct them but mostly that
they represent a part of the world and a
part of the the overall plot because
when I find personally like the if I
think back to like my days at Bioware I
don't think I'd only Bioware was ever we
were never very exceptional at writing
plot it was there it served as it served
its function and it was fine but I was
thought it was the characters that
really drew the players in to the plot
you made characters that represented a
part of the plot that you wanted to play
or to care about because it's far easier
to care about one person and best care
about what they care about as opposed to
being told the kingdom is in danger and
the kingdom is just for the player
really they don't actually live in the
kingdom how do you get the player to
care about the kingdom when it's this
it's this amorphous concept right so
this is this as part of it is like the
this game is introducing a world to the
player sure I don't have to introduce
the concept of a car yes but I do have
to introduce the concept of who the
idols are what what the chorus aisles is
what the gods are Colts just bt-dubs I
don't think we've said that publicly yet
but oh there goes my information yeah
yes that's right but I still have to
introduce all these these concepts the
player and
have you know have the the pieces of the
mystery for the the player to pick
through yeah I mean but I was because
it's very interesting to me that Bioware
has a lot of moving parts but everyone I
know who's a huge Bioware fan and when
they dig into the Dragon Age games the
Mass Effect games it's the characters
that they want to talk about people
aren't I mean the other elements are fun
and engaging but the first things I mean
this is why later in this theater we're
running a panel on a Bioware's love
interests because that's what excites
people I mean having forming those
connections yeah we have a lot of really
cool characters that we've worked really
hard to bring to life and the art
director Benjamin AE has done such an
incredible job of reimagining the Greek
gods in contemporary life I'm working
with Dave to you know
twist and subvert them in various ways
because you know a couple of thousand
years is a very long time hmm well you
did already mention a romance but you
have made a dream dedi comparison with
this game so I'm gonna bring it up again
how much romance can we expect in course
and I'm glad I'm on this slide while
we're talking I do see the thing is for
me romance went over well in Bioware
games no question about it and the
characters were our strengths but the
one thing I always kind of regretted
about romance as an element in Bioware
games is that it was tertiary you could
engage or not engage and if you did
engage it was still a entirely separate
from the main plot like you you engaged
with it entirely separately and had its
own arc and ended and it didn't really
intersect with the main plot so that
that is the thing we want to do here we
do have forum it's it is still optional
but if you start it it becomes part of
the main plot and will affect the ending
I love their room is the other part of a
folk move on the other part of like
being a small game is there aren't like
a whole lot of romances but the romance
is that it there are gonna be like in
great debts you'll get to know these
characters and who you romance will
actually influence the end game and
directly influence the what happens at
the end they will step in maybe they
will you know Stefan at a crucial moment
and and it's been as days are really
important to us to make sure that you
know romance actually means something
yeah and the number is going to well
it's still to be determined
well we touched on a little bit with the
branching dialogue choices but I'd love
to know from each of you what sort of
systems and mechanics in games you
personally find most interesting and
important and if those preferences have
influenced your design choices okay yeah
it's hot I mean like branching dialogue
obviously I feel like that's a that's
obviously given yeah
for us I think a lot of you know from
old-school adventure games to and
finding ways to navigate through worlds
that are accessible one thing that you
know we talked about early on was making
the game as accessible as possible to
make sure that everyone could play it
for a lot of people who don't play a lot
of games like on mobile etc trying to
use a controller for example and where
you have two sticks
thank you move the camera and navigate a
character to the world is actually very
difficult and we wanted to try to remove
the barrier to entry so that everyone
could play this game while still being
really pretty and so how the way we came
about that we talked about for a long
time like how are we gonna do this and
we ended up sort of cut back to the
basics being like well how did that
happen
like not all and then we tested that out
and it actually works really well and
the world still feels very lively and it
feels like you by moving through spaces
it's also a lot cheaper as it turns out
and so it allowed us to make a
a really lived in world without the
budget of a massive triple-a game for me
I think they the the the one little
element Iowa's like is when you have
menu driven dialog drops just like say
and fall out or ever when there are
options that are dependent upon your
traits or choices you made earlier and
you get this the like on staff week we
used that some of that in a byword games
as well for me I always like those
especially if you've got one and it's
like great out and you're like do I have
to replay and do it entirely okay to
find out what's behind that I like it
and I also hate it but I think I like it
more it surveys a designer I like
inflicting it on players we appreciate
it I was when I was thinking about your
game it the only thing I could think
about that made me sort of draw parallel
and I suppose either of you ever played
the bods tale by an exile I'm not in
2004 yes so that's the only kind of the
only game I could personally think of it
was it all like a well it was more of an
action II game an adventure game that
had musical elements I still remember
the song they song about beer did anyone
else play that game in the audience I
mean the fact and I always wanted them
do you like brute like brute into that
area of further because it's just
something that doesn't happen and yet
that game is so memorable not for the
combat but I remember these like song
about beer that they sing at the stop
yeah there are games that certainly the
music has taken is more important or
even it has like a piece of it that like
you can even Inquisition had the when
you had the low moment scene where the
the mother mother gazelle thank you I
was about to say mother what's-her-face
this is my last day of constantly
forgets character name mother Giselle
comes out in the stinking sings the song
right but it is not a gameplay element
ever it's it's just sometimes it's
important but it's still background
essentially right but yeah and I mean
but there
have been games where music is a
functional element I mean if you look at
journey and you know the music in almost
interacts with you as you play and
there's dominic has anyone played
Dominic Pomplamoose another very cool
like musical game there I think one of
the old double flying games or double
final before then Guybrush Threepwood
actually there's like a battle song that
you know like it's been around yes you
know it's been around these ideas have
been around but I have had the focus of
a game and yeah I mean like even when it
is an outside element I mean do you guys
think music has more of a role to play
and how affecting ah'd in gameplay
experiences can be yeah yeah that in
fact what what uh Austin I think wintery
was was really sort of driving for when
we met up with him he's he's told us
he's thought for quite some time that it
can do a lot more than it currently does
and it has so much room to explore yeah
yeah I think that that is part of the
point of us of us doing this that you
can have a story that doesn't
necessarily need a dialogue to carry you
along entirely I think for many of us
music is a shortcut to to our emotions
and you can I think I think the
potential is there to to get emotional
buy-in from the players so much more
quickly cuts well just to be nice and
broad in case there's something you're
dying to say that I haven't given you a
window for what is each of your favorite
things about the game so far what you're
trying to do and what you're creating it
was one thing I was 2.0 you say it's
many things we're just happy to have you
yeah we're just happy to be here yeah
what else what are you looking for
looking forward to uh what's exciting
you about the game look at the idea of
just working on a musical isn't really
cool and the caliber of talent like
working with Laura Bailey is such an
incredible talent is is really fantastic
and and Troy and Austin like we have
been so
hashtag blessed to work with these
incredibly talented passionate people
sorry hey Roble
I know oh I felt it and you know there's
something really special about when you
get to work in a team that cares so
leave for what they're doing I think
it's saying that you don't get to
experience very often and the way in
which this project came together was
definitely like a like a like a merging
of creative minds and passion and so for
me it's less about what I mean obviously
I'm looking forward to the rest of the
game hopefully with your help but it's
also what's come before and the process
that we've been through and you know
it's it's pretty special
it's the friends you made along the way
by the way I'm also really really
looking forward to people learning more
about this F&E who is so badass so bad I
like Wow
that row of butch lesbian energy is very
real great for me tough thing is when I
when I do write the narratives
I often leave little little um I dangled
carrots for myself it's the way I keep
myself writing and there's always a
couple of things that I that I get
really excited about like if I get to
kill someone important or whatever is
like it's like the I I will write this
boring part of the story because I
really want to get to the carrot right
and it's like but I can't I can't
describe the carrots without getting
spoilery the only thing that that right
now that I really am excited about is
that the ending musical scene is so
complex and I don't even know how I'm
gonna do it
I'm really excited to get to that point
to try I think I may have to leave that
particular carrot like dangle it for the
very end just just to be sure that I
actually reached the finish line you
know and then we'll get there and movie
as a group will set around be like so
how are we gonna do this I think we'll
need all the experience that we can get
to do that this it's gonna be wild yeah
yeah all righty well I do want to open
this up to questions we should have a
little bit of time so if anyone has a
question if you want to line up at eat
either of these microphones it's kind of
back here midway down the room and do
keep in mind there are awesome things
that the guys won't be able to answer at
this stage of development so you know
everyone be nice will be nice about it
but um having said that to make a
gamespot I use news writer Eddie Mack
you happy I will ask if there's any
sweet scoops you can give us interesting
stuff new characters honestly the color
of the UI I'm sure he'll be able to
write a new story on you got anything
you got wait we haven't talked a lot
about herpes so Hermes as David
mentioned earlier is one of the younger
generation of gods he's not super
important in the scheme of things but
he's also the connective tissue that
kind of pulls everything together
because he's literally the connector
between worlds
yes is there anything else that you want
to share
about Emmys you just said it I mean like
there's a lot more there is more than he
does in the plot but I don't want to
talk about that mm okay well I have a
very important question that you
probably won't want to reveal at this
time but dis Apollo have some kind of
Mount Olympus gym to get those abs or
their gods not have to work out I think
it's natural I think it just is
ah right right it's just like that
that's disgusting
oh that it that is my favorite thing
about Apollo though the one thing he has
and here's the he always has Paolo
always has a kind Oracle an Oracle and
he doesn't someone just shows up yeah
eventually when when the previous one
dies and he has it has an Oracle in this
case he's living in a you know basically
a dump by the by the sea and he has this
this young 14 year old grows sort of a
computer whiz who totally doesn't
doesn't believe that she's an Oracle at
all like she just Google's stuff for him
and tells him well this is the thing and
he says thank you Oracle and she's like
yeah whatever but then all her friends
say but they're like but you but you
hang out with him aren't you kind of his
Oracle he's like no I could leave at any
time and they're like what you don't
that's the thing I like it I think it's
cool about it but Paolo that's pretty
fantastic that's even better than the
ABS oh my um all right well why don't we
start over on these sides
Oh microphone please please make my
finger well well we're making the
microphone go do head to the campaign
link you can just go to like eco /chorus
yeah or you can go to the big
complicated one that I wrote up both
okay uh we all good to go hello yes
hello I have voices oh thank you sir I
have a question about so for your first
game you've got a female main character
um and I was just wondering cuz even in
2019 like that can be a bit of a scary
thing to do which sucks right right um
yeah I was just wondering like how did
you come to that choice was it just like
a natural thing with the story did you
do it intentionally to make a point
oh we talked about it mmm but whether
the feasibility of having ability to
play both genders for one whether we
would have a male protagonist or a
female protagonist I think because we
involved the muse that is eventually why
we settled on a female character at
least at least for now we will see how
the campaign progresses whether other
options open up for us thank you I love
any female protagonist we're pretty
passionate about it - hi I just had a
brief question you mentioned in passing
flow
yes wondering if you could expand any a
little bit on on how that works is it
like other rhythm elements within the
song and not rhythm elements what flow
is is at a point a point value system
like a like a bucket of points that you
build up while a song is going on every
option you select in the song will add
flow or remove it actually yes so you're
trying to build up a pool of flow points
we call them so that when you get to the
end of the song those are your those are
the options where you you spend flow in
order to generate an effect upon the
world that's how that's how the mute
that's the muses power uses songs aren't
succeed or fail there's a there's a
series of different
and there is no fail in our game like
yeah yeah it's just there's a different
route through the plot basically okay
thanks I um how does writing for a game
where the main character is sort of
predefined compared to your previous
work at Bioware where the main character
was much more determined by the player
choices yeah it's it's it's interesting
I mean it's it's always a there's a a
[Music]
spectrum clearly what else but a Spectre
between how defined a character is
versus when you have an undefined
character how much the player gets her
to put themselves in there like whether
you are the character and it has to
directly identify or whether you were
sort of controlling a character that you
perhaps Caribou but perhaps don't
directly identify with I mean you can
have very good stories like even RPGs
various kinds like one thing comes to
mind Planescape torment is perhaps an
example of a classic RPG where you don't
can you - you're not that character at
all but you do control what they become
and this is the same thing here so it
was interesting it's the first time I've
ever been able to have NPCs address my
player by name which sounds like a small
thing but is really annoying when you're
trying to write it or a romance scene I
love you Inquisitor
sounds so impersonal
so that that's that's fun but it just
say involves a slightly different route
where you don't you you aren't grace but
you are affecting the type of grace that
that is that is coming through the story
we have different versions of grace with
the trait system that that become
emphasized the more you go down that
particular path thank you yeah hi
so currently how many wild karaoke
nights have been claimed back as
research are you with the tax office
if so the answer is none like maybe a
couple yeah I think I think the most
popular one is a pop star okay
which which basically came out at the
same time as we were writing like one of
our early prototypes which ended up
sounding remarkably similar somehow and
say yeah like thanks legal legends yeah
we do a lot of cash yeah it's sort of
become our whenever the the the team
goes out to sort of celebrate a
milestone or something we'd go sing
karaoke that our voices are very hoarse
for you the next few days I mean we
don't even have to go to karaoke to sing
like unfortunately for literally
everyone around us at the office there's
a lot of singing that goes on every now
and again somebody we were to [ __ ] we're
in a shared space at the arcade so there
are other brewery in the same building
with other companies every now and again
someone will come and they'll poke their
head in their inner office and just
blows our door fair fair we do a lot of
singing one massive musical theater nerd
to another is there any like musical
theater shows that you say maybe your
favorites or ones that are having an
influence on the show that you want to
influence I mean the one that we bring
up a lot of course is the Buffy musical
not just because of the the that it is a
musical but I mean the fact that it
exists in a fantastical setting that the
music is die genic it's like it's in
world so everyone it isn't just like
that we're singing and it's a narrative
frame device
you know the characters were actually
singing and the people are aware of that
they're singing and that's the part that
I that I that I like about it but in
terms of other musicals into the woods
into the world a lot of Sun hi I'm a big
fans of Hades town yeah when we eighties
town hipsters because we were fans of it
before went abroad yeah we we kind of
like scrubbed out the basis of our story
and then found out about Hades town and
we're like [ __ ] yeah like this is
awesome something like dear Evan Hanson
I'm a huge fan of stuff like A Chorus
Line and company and like old school as
well say Book of Mormon
okay moment yeah like this is it time
and like we're yeah we in the office
right now there's just like all of these
straight books on our desk which I
brought in the other day because there's
a lot the reason we bring up Broadway a
lot is that when we're approaching the
songs because you have to understand the
songs and so each of them has its own
narrative arc it's much more similar to
how a Broadway song is is constructed as
opposed to say a rock song where you
yours how if that's how danceable it is
it's the the refrain you we can't do
that quite the same we need we need a
story if you if you listen to the a song
that said that's in the trailer the one
that the Laura sings there's a definite
path through this song right the
beginning of the song she's like my life
is crazy right then it's and I am
actually frightened and maybe going to
die and then the path ends with this and
a song with no I can't let this I can't
let this stop me I have to win that's
the kind of route you need to take any
song Thanks
it might have time for two more so yeah
go ahead
what sort of romantic diversity have you
worked into the game is it
so you mentioned Persephone is raw butch
lesbian energy have you got any other
sort of like either non-monogamous or
bias or any sort of that we're not
talking about that yet sorry thank you
we we really want to answer that
question but wait yeah I'm sure in the
fantastic question hi thank you um I
wanted to ask about how you go about
writing the interactions of characters
in games between other characters and
their environment as oh that's that's uh
that's a big question like you can have
a entire discussion on that all on its
own um I think the only trick that can
really suggest and as a short answer is
to read it out loud the thing I find if
you're if you're talking about how to do
dialogue read it out loud and and
that'll be your big your quickest sense
to feeling if it's natural and that's
what you want you want to be able to
imagine that this is what somebody would
actually say how people would actually
communicate I think when the author's
live in their head it's very easy to to
go delete going a little bit too
fanciful I wrote I would also add um I
find it very helpful to have a very
strong sense of character sorry if I
know how with the characters are and how
they react to situations I can put them
in an environment and then kind of just
like a kid play and because I have a
strong sense of who they are and and how
they'll react to things I can kind of
like play them against each other
and it kind of it's like a logical
progression because it just makes sense
for those characters thank you let's
take one last question because I'm
pushing it but go ahead so you mentioned
that creepy is the muse that grace meets
if you're using the hellenistic model of
9muses is there a reason you've chosen
the muse of epic poetry as opposed to
any of the ones of dance lyric or
rhythm yes that reason sorry can you
share that reason oh yeah no I
understood half of what you said but you
guys fantastic alright um you're already
doing it but please join me in thank you
thank you for coming
I wish you all the best if you guys are
excited for the game you know Whitaker
um yes very money at them they're doing
a very exciting thing and do come back
as I said to this very theater at 5:00
p.m. tonight where we'll be deciding who
is the ultimate Bioware love interest on
a panel with navigator himself hope to
see you there and thanks a lot guys
thanks everyone thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like II like when you [ __ ] with my mind
like that were wrong
boys a more perfect see the revenge in
your eyes goodbye
pull the trigger
mr. masterpiece
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you
you
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you